non
le passé ne meurent jamais
james le destin nous réunit à nouveau
à présent mon ennemi est mon ami
il s'appelle sa fille qu'est-ce qu'il
veut se venger
ouais t'es que son secret remontera la
surface ça te tuera à coup sûr comprenez
que je veuille revenir dans la partie
il ya une jeune femme à santiago que
j'aimerais que tu rencontres vous êtes
en retard
c'est comme vous voulez
salud
j'ai rencontré votre nouvelle double
zéro une jeune femme vraiment des arbres
je comprends que vous lui avait tiré
dessus tout le monde a essayé au moins
une fois
j'aime ce pas
nous et radicaux ont déjà tous les deux
pour créer un monde meilleur mais moi
j'essaie d'être un peu plus méticuleux
[Applaudissements]
ou encore
piloter ce genre d'argent
c'est plus en plus dur de se séparer le
bien du mal des méchants des héros nos
jours
qu'est-ce que ça tu te rends pas compte
et il va tuer des millions de gens
si on réussit pas
il n'y aura plus rien à sauver
[Musique]